David Dorn is not a name on the lips of
our leaders this week should be Doren
served his community for almost 40 years
as a police officer even half after he
retired he continued to help others
last weekend Dorn was in st. Louis
trying to protect a friend store from
looters and he was murdered for doing it
this country ought to remember Dorn he
represents the best of America instead
his name has been shoved down the memory
hole the media would like him forgotten
the immediate least they can go back to
in flaming hateful violence across our
nation we should not let that happen he
was not the only victim by the way of
these riots and not the only victim who
has been forgotten we think that's a
shame on Twitter former White House
speechwriter Darren Beattie and good for
him has been keeping track of the
casualties of this rioting and we want
to read some of them to you because it's
important to remember people who've been
killed more than just one many David
Patrick Underwood was a Federal
Protective Service officer in California
a week ago he was shot to death we don't
know who killed him he was protecting a
federal building in Oakland one of his
colleagues was also critically injured
in that shooting
Italian Marine Kelly was just 22 years
old she was attending a George Floyd
related protest in Davenport Iowa she
became uncomfortable with the direction
of that protest understandably she got
in her car to leave and she was killed
by a stray bullet shot dead Jose
Gutierrez was a bystander he was
watching as others looted the Chicago
suburb of Cicero for being there he was
shot in the head and killed by this man
Xion Haygood that's what police say
another victim in Cicero Illinois was
Viktor Cesare his junior he was 27 he
was shot to death outside a grocery
store no one remembers his name we
should in Minneapolis Francisco Monte L
who's 46 was found dead next to a
burned-out car police attributed his
death to quote complex homicidal
violence that's obvious he was a
casualty of the riots at least three
people were murdered during the violence
in Indianapolis one of them was 38
year-old former Indiana football player
Chris Baty he was found shot to death
just outside his apartment an unnamed
latino man in his 20s was also killed on
Sunday in Los Angeles in an area that
was completely demolished by
dieters and of course those are just the
ones who were killed probably not an
exhaustive list if you know more please
send them to us thousands have been hurt
maimed financially ruined brain damaged
over the past week dozens of those are
police officers they were injured trying
to protect the public one of them is Las
Vegas police officer Shane McKellen as
he was shot during the riot on Monday
the man who shot him says it was an
accident he was just trying to scare a
rioters we don't know the truth but the
man took a bullet to the head the police
officer did every one of those people
deserves to be remembered but instead
again they are forgotten and they're
forgotten on purpose the press would
like these protests to go down in
history is mostly peaceful they're not
and they're not in part because CNN
MSNBC The New York Times and many others
have been in flamin racial tensions
around the country they're inciting
violence they don't care about the
consequences the rest of us should care
those are human beings they're Americans
and now they're gone and you know who
did it the people on our streets they
should be held accountable for what they
did well for months and months you'll
remember our leaders made it illegal for
you to protest anything even to go to
church the coronavirus lockdowns were in
the force but now that our streets are
overrun with black lives matter protests
and riots they've changed their minds
your protests are still illegal they're
racist the ones destroying our country
essential I'll tell you what they said
after the break